THE PEAK OF YAHOO:
Once upon a time, Yahoo was one
of the largest internet companies in the world.
They offered everything from search and email
to weather and stocks. They were basically the
Google of the late 1990s and early 2000s with a
monstrous valuation of $125 billion way back then.
But, ever since then, it’s only been downhill for
Yahoo. Yahoo only pulls in a mere fraction
of the internet traffic what they used to,
and this has translated to underwhelming
stats across the company. At this point,
they don’t even control 3% of the search engine
market which is 3 times less than even Bing,
and it’s a similar case with email as well.
They’re no longer even a public company and
they keep getting tossed around from one owner
to another for pennies on the dollar. In fact,
Apollo Funds recently bought Yahoo and AOL,
both of whom were once $100 billion companies,
and other businesses all for just $5 billion.
But, more than all of that, likely the worst
omen for Yahoo is public perception. I don’t
think people necessarily have a negative view
of Yahoo but at the same time, it’s not positive
either. If you ask the average person about Yahoo,
they’re response would probably be along the lines
of “Oh yeah, they used to be really big back in
the day. I think I still have a yahoo email from
back then but I don’t use it anymore.” In other
words, the general public has very much moved
on from Yahoo, and most would point to Google
as being the biggest reason for Yahoo’s downfall.
And at first glance that makes sense. After all,
it was Google that basically overtook every
industry that Yahoo used to dominate. It’s the
classic case of a new modern company displacing a
legacy giant with raw innovation and charm. But,
when we peel back the layers, you’ll see that
almost all of Yahoo’s demise was actually their
own fault. So, here’s what really happened to
Yahoo - the company that threw away everything.
A LUCKY BREAK:
To understand what really happened to Yahoo,
we first have to understand how they even
became successful in the first place. Usually,
when we talk about dying companies on the channel,
we’re talking about some legacy electronics
company that was founded in the 1960s and 70s or
even the early 1900s, but Yahoo doesn’t exactly
fit this profile. If anything, Yahoo is more of a
new age company having not been founded till 1994.
Yahoo actually has a very similar origin story
to Google. You know how Google was founded by two
Stanford graduate students, Sergey Brin and Larry
Page, in the 1990s? Well, Yahoo, was also founded
by two Stanford graduate student, Jerry Yang and
David Filo in the 1990s. Yahoo even had a crappy
original name just like Google. It was originally
called Jerry and David's Guide to the World Wide
Web. As the name suggests, Yahoo started off as
a way to better navigate the World Wide Web but
not by searching. Instead, Yahoo was more of
an online phone book. It was basically just
a massive directory of websites. That probably
sounds rather clunky for 2023 standards but back
in 1994, this itself was pretty useful. In fact,
before the name Yahoo was even chosen, our duo
would receive over 100,000 visitors and 1 million
views to their website. Surprised by the traffic,
our duo would decide to make this side project an
official business and name it Yahoo which stands
for “Yet Another Hierarchically Organized Oracle”.
And with that, Yahoo was off to the races. Just
one month after being incorporated, Yahoo would
raise $3 million from Michael Moritz and Sequoia
Capital. And just an year after that, Yahoo would
IPO on April 12, 1996 reaching a valuation of $1
billion. Let me put that another way. Yahoo went
from 0 to $1 billion within a matter of 2 years
and 4 months, and for most of that time period,
they weren’t even an official company. Yeah,
I think it’s safe to say that Yahoo very much
stumbled into the limelight and this was likely
one of their biggest shortfalls. Yahoo wasn’t
some sort of super well thought out company. It
was something that kind of just happened and this
would become really apparent when Yahoo was tasked
with maintaining and growing this success. Luckily
for Yahoo though, they never had to deal with this
during the 90s thanks to dotcom hype. Instead of
growing a strong foundation, Yahoo would have the
luxury of expanding into everything underneath
the sun using dotcom money. For example, they
would launch a bunch of international variants of
Yahoo throughout 1996. This included Yahoo Japan,
Yahoo UK, Yahoo Germany, and Yahoo France. They
would even start their own print magazine called
Yahoo! Internet Life. Yeah, I don’t think you’d
be surprised to hear that this magazine didn’t
last all that long but Yahoo also had a
few stellar launches as well like Yahoo
Mail and Yahoo Finance in 1997. But if there
was any way to describe Yahoo in the late 90s,
it would be that they were all over the place.
Like a lot of tech companies try to do, Yahoo
was trying to be everything for everyone. And
who could blame them? They were growing rapidly,
had access to seemingly infinite capital,
and they would even be added to the S&P 500.
It wasn’t until the turn of the century and
things cooled down that Yahoo would realize
that by trying to be everything for everyone,
they had actually become nothing to no one.
PURE INCOMPETENCE:
Being all over the place
and lacking focus was just half the story though.
Much of Yahoo’s demise can actually be attributed
to pure incompetence and poor decision making
and likely the best example of this was was their
history of acquisitions. Acquisitions can be a
gamechanger. Some of the most successful tech
ventures of all time weren’t built in house, they
were acquisitions. This includes the likes of
YouTube, Android, Instagram, and WhatsApp all of
which were game changers for Google and Facebook.
Yahoo has had their own share of gamechanging
acquisitions, only it wasn’t gamechanging in a
good way. And it wasn’t just 1 or 2 bad deals
either. Yahoo consistently made terrible deals
starting with Google. You see, Larry and Sergey
didn’t initially have massive ambitions with
Google. As far as they were concerned, Google was
just a school project and they were willing to
sell project for a generous exit of $1 million
in 1998 to none other than Yahoo. Yahoo would
of course refuse, and honestly, this is quite
understandable. They probably see dozens of
people like Larry and Sergey walk through the door
and most of them likely end up as nothing. So,
it’s understandable that Yahoo didn’t want to take
a flyer with Google in 98, but you know what they
did wanna take a flyer with: the most overvalued
internet company of all time: Broadcast.com. I’m
not even exaggerating. Broadcast.com is regularly
cited as the worst acquisition of all time as
Yahoo would pay $5.7 billion for the company.
The company only had a total of 570,000 users,
meaning that Yahoo paid $10,000 per user. If
that wasn’t bad enough, Yahoo would end up
shutting down the company just a few years later.
And that was just the most notable example. Yahoo
also blew $3.6 billion on GeoCities, $1.63
billion on Overture, $1 billion on Tumblr,
and $850 million on Right Media. Clearly,
not a very strong track record but honestly,
the deals that Yahoo missed out on are even more
notable. Remember how they missed out on Google
in 98? Well, that was just the first time that
they missed out on Google. It turns out that they
would somehow get a second chance in 2002 and
they would blow it once again. At this point,
Google was no longer just a college project. It
was a legitimate business that was rapidly eating
up Yahoo’s market share. Yahoo realized this and
would offer to buy Google for $3 billion. Google
would counter with $5 billion but Yahoo was not
willing to budge. For perspective, Google would
reach a $100 billion valuation just 3 years later.
Alright, maybe Yahoo is just unlucky when it
comes to Google. If another winner walked through,
surely they would pounce right? Well, Google isn’t
the end of the story because Yahoo also missed out
on Facebook in 2006, and this one was the saddest
of them all actually. Everything was good to go.
Both parties had agreed to a acquisition for $1.1
billion. But, at the last second, Yahoo would
reduce their offer to $800 million and Zucerkberg
would walk away. In other words, Yahoo has lost
out on trillion dollar opportunities on 3 separate
occasions. Fortunately, that was the last time
they massively screwed it up, I’m just kidding.
After all, this is Yahoo that we’re talking about.
In 2013, Yahoo had the opportunity to either buy
Tumblr for $1.1 billion, Hulu for $1.3 billion, or
Netflix for $4 billion. They would end up choosing
Tumblr while Netflix became the best performing
stock of the decade. To be honest, I didn’t even
know this was within the realm of possibility.
They literally passed on 3 FAANG companies on 4
separate occasions while simultaneously making the
worst acquisitions of history. It’s actually wild.
They somehow managed to perfectly pick all the
losers and miss out on all the winners. Sounds a
lot like your average joe trying to day trade and
honestly that was pretty much what happened. Yahoo
was led by extremely intelligent people but not
exactly strong business people. Google actually
had the exact same problem. Larry and Sergey
are some of the smartest people in the world,
but they weren’t all that great at being CEOs. And
that’s why they hired a career business man named
Eric Schmidt to be CEO, and Eric is really the guy
who made the business side of Google work. Yahoo,
however, didn’t have an Eric, and they would
continuously blow it year after year. And if
you thought their history of acquisitions
was terrible, well it get’s even worse.
THE SHAMEFUL DEMISE:
Despite all of their blunders
and shortcomings, Microsoft, who was desperate to
fight against Google would offer to buy out Yahoo
in 2008 for $45 billion. While this was a lot
lower than Yahoo’s peak valuation of $125 billion,
it was quite generous given that Yahoo was
getting destroyed by Google, but Yahoo didn’t
see it this way. They saw it as an under market
value offer so they would decline the deal and
this basically sealed their fate. Yahoo would
continue getting destroyed by Google over the
next decade and they would eventually get bought
out by Verizon for a measly $4.5 billion. Today,
Yahoo is still around and they still have a decent
user count just because of how big they were back
in their glory days. But make no mistake, Yahoo is
a shell of their former selves and what happened
to them is really quite a shame. Yahoo basically
accidently stumbled upon a gold mine in the 90s
but they didn’t exactly know how to manage all
this new found wealth. They ended up expanding
into every sector under the sun while not doing
any of them all that well. This would’ve been
the end for most companies but thanks to
dotcom funding and hype, they were able to
overcome these massive mistakes. They had a second
opportunity to really double down on their core
products and audience, but they never did that
and Google would end up eating their lunch. Now,
this would’ve surely been the end of most
companies but Yahoo had even more opportunities
should in the form of acquisitions. First, there
was Google, then Google again, then Facebook, then
a bailout from Microsoft, and then Netflix. Yet,
Yahoo would pass on all of these opportunities
only to end up being bought out by Verizon for
$4.5 billion. And honestly, Yahoo has no one to
blame but themselves. You know how 70% of lottery
winners end up going bankrupt within a few years,
well, that’s exactly what happened to Yahoo. They
got insanely lucky but without the right business
mindset, they just weren’t able to keep up their
success despite having every opportunity to do
so. Another company that threw away everything
is Xerox. Check out this video to learn more.